anyway hello folks welcome to rational
science finally we got our equipment
working I hope everything's okay I hope
you can hear me fine finally got a good
laptop please let me know if you're
receiving signal uh sound uh video the
whole works
okay okay
if someone would confirm you can look it
up there as
well
okay okay so let's get started we had a
little bit of problems uh yesterday
technical
problems but the good news for me at
least is after two
months okay thank you uh after two
months I found my son UNS I don't know
where but we found him in the middle of
a desert yeah and uh did you start that
war in Israel because just as soon as
you left the war started that was me
guys okay just wonder okay anyways uh we
got a great show today we're going to be
talking about what dark energy why are
we talking about Dark Energy I have no
idea why but that's what we're going to
talk about well because we're on a roll
uh talking about um uh the universe
lately we've been talking about the
universe for two months different
aspects of it relativity and so on talk
about yeah yeah there even Beyond
relativity if we're talking about actual
Universe yeah complicated and and the
big problem that uh we have out there is
language language language and language
uh a lot of people think that um anyone
who does language does clarification of
language is doing word Wizardry word
salad uh semantics uh minor stuff
wasting their time yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like uh for them it's just no noise
coming in the ear and coming out the
other so what we do we start with uh and
I'm going to be starting today with um
some of the questions and comments
people made because that's going to lead
into the subject matter of today so I'm
going to work it in reverse instead of
answering the questions at the end today
we're going to start by answering
questions that people ask because they
they're they're related to the subject
matter of today okay so uh let me start
with this uh what we do in this channel
we like to put the what is known as the
universal movie I do have to say before
we start I like that when I look up
rational science this the first thing
that shows up what we're the only people
doing rational science oh yeah
that's anyways here we have the
universal movie and what it is you have
to imagine the universe every atom in
the universe has location that's all it
has okay and in the next uh microsc
billionth of a second quadrillionth of a
second every atom in the universe is is
at a different location so uh they
everything moves from location to
location to location and in one of those
frames all we have is location of every
object in the universe so think of that
as a 3D movie and one of the problems we
have is that a lot of people especially
dissonants um they uh use uh Concepts as
physical objects specifically the ones
that I circled there plasma and ether
the lishment also uses field but those
are the three words that are always used
as physical objects well to the thing
that they the concept is used the most
as a physical object would have to be
motion mov is indirectly indect yeah
indirectly movement is moved the most
yeah if you say to people is motion a a
physical object they'll say no but if
you say is plasma ether fi or energy a
physical object well people have
problems with that they they think these
are physical object
and as you can see I put them at the
bottom because those concepts are
Dynamic Concepts they take at least two
frames of the universal movie whereas
the ones on the top in yellow they only
uh they only occupy one frame of the
universal movie okay so that's
essentially what we're trying to show
there and uh what we'll see today is
some of the questions that I'm going to
be answering today are related to
Dynamic Concepts which people treat as
physical objects that's the whole
problem okay so it is a language problem
and again for them it's just noise in
their ear they say I came here to do
physics not Grammar not yeah yeah yeah
we have to do aund physics is 150%
semantics I wish it weren't but you
gotta you got to Define your terms you
got to tell us what you mean by the
words it's not really but it it has
become that way since people have abused
it for so long now it's become the first
thing that you look at absolutely it's
just because due to the abuse of the of
the English language English and any or
any language that is done in and it's
important to note that mathematics is
only a language I mean uh people say
well the language of physics is
mathematics well is the language of
physics Chinese is the language of
physics Greek you know it's Greek to me
and so it's that's the language of
physics no uh the language of physics is
illustration if you're going to be
explaining a mechanism okay so we got to
keep that in mind
so one fell says the following let's get
started here he says the following he
says um uh seems unfair your definition
of plasma right plasma is a highly
ionized gas and then next slide you
define ionization okay ionized is past
tense okay it's already ionized you know
finished like he imagines it if chemical
reactions are occurring in air it
doesn't make any uh make it any less of
a gas okay so what is this fellow saying
well he's saying essentially this he's
saying look here we have uh ionized gas
or ionized atoms on the left hand side
you take a snapshot of it which is the
one you see on the uh right hand side
right and uh he says well it's already
ionized the one on the right is already
ionized Ed you know finished and the
question is if I take a snapshot of
ionized gas ionized atoms uh can we say
that plasma is a static concept because
I was able to put it in a snapshot okay
so that's the question and the the
answer is no because um the word plasma
already embodies motion let me repeat
that because I don't think that's sunk
in so easily the word plasma already
embodies motion and what we should be
doing is really maybe defining plasma so
that these people understand is instead
of ionized atoms
we should be calling them constantly
ionizing atoms because they're
constantly being ionized plasma never
stands still because if it does all the
electrons recombine with their atoms and
so uh and it turns into gas so we we
cannot stop the word plasma what this
person is trying to take a picture of is
not atoms or gas he's trying to take a
picture of
ionized or ionizing ionizing and you
can't that requires two frames of the
movie and here let me give because you
is it because you have to have
the with the ion and then without it no
the issue is that uh plasma is is a
mixture right of atoms uh together with
normal atoms that have not been ionized
that have not uh lost their electrons
right together with other atoms that
have lost their electrons if we're going
with a quantum mechan meic version which
is really the one these people have in
mind so some atoms have their have lost
their electrons some atoms have not and
it's a soup it's a mixture something is
stimulating that ionization constantly
but if someone took a picture of a has
already lost it uh its electron ionized
gas they have a picture of just the part
where it's where the electron is out
yeah yeah yeah yeah I hear you I
understand you yeah now what wouldn't
can you point to that and say that's
plasma no because the word plasma means
ionized not gas it means ionized and
you're trying to take a picture of a
verb that's
that's line well no here here here so
here's the here's here we can see it I
think I think you'll understand what
what my argument is uh what semantics uh
word Wizardry word Sal okay here here's
a little word salad for you okay here we
have it on the left hand side we see a
running boy yeah okay that's a
movie a single see it now okay on the
right side you have a boy and you say
well I took a picture of a running boy
yeah no you you you haven't taken a
picture of running you took a picture of
boy okay running requires you can't take
a picture of running because running
always requires two frames of movie gas
is still just gas well it's uh ionized
you're trying to take a picture of ioned
like here you're take a picture of
running but if you were to take a
picture of ionized gas you say that it's
just gas because you're trying to add
the running the gas yeah because you're
really not taking a picture of gas
itself because it's not the question is
not whether you took a picture of gas
you took a picture of what is known as
plasma but the word plasma has that
adjective in front of it it's called
ioniz iing but if someone brought a
picture of plasma to you it would be as
if it were the the boy that were in one
frame running you would say it's just
gas you could say that but even even
there you would need to have a
comparison to you know without the
ionization in other words no no what I'm
saying is if you if you try to explain
it to an ET right and you say look
there's a little a bunch of little balls
there and the smaller balls which are
the electrons they out he won't know
what he's looking at he's looking at a
bunch of balls that's all all it is
really for him he just say is gas right
yeah at you would say it's a gas or just
a bunch of balls you would have to
explain to him what it is but my point
here is another one my point is that you
you're trying to take a picture of a
verb you're trying to take a picture of
running you're trying to take a picture
of ionizing well you said something
interesting yesterday that I still was
trying to WP my head yeah you said that
physics I don't know if everyone here
agrees with this let's see if we get a
show of hands
physics I don't know how you phrased it
but something like does not require or
does not need adjectives yeah you can't
use there's no such thing as a dead cat
like in Schrodinger's cat right there's
no such thing as a live cat there's no
such thing as a green tree as a brown
house uh you know there's only a thing
called House Superfluous poetry is that
that what what adjectives have become
you cannot put a an adjective in front
of a noun for the purposes of physics in
physics we point to an object and we
don't say it's the green house no no no
such thing as a green house there's only
such thing as a House Green is an
adjective and now you're qualifying it
you're comparing it brown blue and other
types of houses so you're making a
comparison if you just want to point to
the object you say house cat dog so
you're saying if this were a court of
law that'd be grounds for an objection
objection used an adjective but you said
adverbs are fair game yeah well I'm
saying adjectives do not come together
with nouns in physics in physics you
point to the noun to the cat to the dog
to the Rock to the tree to the house you
point you know and say chair you don't
say that's the brown chair no such thing
as a brown chair in physics has an
object is it because we don't care is is
it always unnecessary information does
it just muddy the water are you m it
muddies the water adding motion what are
we doing here well people would say well
I can take a picture of ionizing atoms
or ionizing gas no you're you're you're
you're you don't realize it you're
trying to take a picture of ionizing not
of the gas or the atom yeah yeah okay
and here it is this is the definition
now there you have it plasma constantly
ionizing atoms I don't know how else to
Define it so that people don't work try
to work around it you know if it's
constantly ionizing you can't take a
picture of that because as soon as you
take a picture of that you don't have
plasma what you try to do is take a
picture of ionizing and you cannot
remove the word ionizing from the word
plasma that's the issue we have someone
that says constantly balding head
balding is a process you can't just
point to a bald head cuz he's
balding I think he's talking about you
okay
yeah
there okay and here's another aspect to
our good old plasma okay a lot of people
say well bill it's a state of
matter no no absolutely not let me show
you why you cannot use plasma as a
Define it or even qualify it as a state
of matter okay state is a static concept
there's no say seeing a state in two
frames of the movie I think we can all
agree about that okay so state is a
static concept plasma is not so here let
me show you let me show you by that
definition would color be a state well
let's look at this here here we have it
here we have the different states of
matter solid liquid and gas none of
those three require motion oh you got a
gift here can we get the ioniz can I get
the ionizing in a picture see we have
solid uh liquid and gas do not the words
right there's no such physical object
called solid solid is a category you
know you many there are many solids so
solid is a category so is liquid so is
gas but ionizing is something that
involves motion it cannot be a state you
cannot say plasma the fourth state of
matter no state there's only three
states and those are solid liquid and
gas because those three words do not
embody motion whereas the word plasma
does embody motion so plasma is not a
state and I know that destroys the
religion of all of people of the
electric universe who also think that
electricity is a physical object when
electricity is something in motion it's
a movie where do you think the problem
would be are you just seeing such
discrepancies with the categorization
that you're just convinced that at some
point down the line of their
presentation they're going to mess it up
or what well they do mess it up they do
mess it up because uh the electric
Universe says uh for example just an
example here uh gravity is electricity
and they try to explain it with
electricity no gravity cannot be
electricity because you have to identify
the physical object the mediator of
gravity and you cannot say electricity
is the mediator because electricity is
something in motion it's you got to
whatever you present a tree a dog a line
you know whatever it's got to be static
you got to show it and say that's what's
going to serve as the mediator of
gravity you cannot say electricity
because electricity is already in motion
what's wrong with something already
being in motion assuming the universe is
already in motion because in physics uh
uh in science right the scientific
method you have to present the objects
and the definitions first first step
objects and definitions and you have to
point to the object so we know who are
the actors and this guy says I'm going
to present a boy running or running boy
no no you can please present the boy
then you can put them in motion but
please present the boy first well I'm
sure they haven't uh broken down
electricity to the my new level you have
either but are you saying that because
they would have to also take electricity
and say okay what is electricity what is
it that's moving yeah they have to still
break they still have to break down
electricity into the static and the and
the
movement of the static in fact it's even
worse in the sense that they already
know no quotations what electricity
electricity is what quantum mechanics
gave to the electric universe and to all
these people who use electricity as a
mediator and that is you know an
electron bead moving from atom to atom
that's electricity according to the
electric universe and according to the
establishment and so the question is
what what is what is the object well the
object is the at and then you ionize it
in other words you have that electron be
the atom go to another atom and goes to
another one another one that where that
process is called electricity according
to the establishment I don't want to go
too deep into this if you don't want to
but just as a quick last question how
would they H how would you conceptualize
the pull of
gravity are they saying that there's
wires of atoms between everything no
that it it gets even worse because I to
know no no you want to know whether you
like it or not no what they say is
positive and negative where are the
atoms H don't worry about that because
it's all concept say positive attraction
hold on if if electricity is is an
electron going from atom to atom
whatever an electron is right but that
that implies that there's rows of
atoms and what you have is the electron
No in fact they got rid of the atom too
all they have is electrons moving now
without any now we're just shooting guns
just shooting beads so the electrons go
from positive to uh yeah from you know
towards a positive pole yeah and and
where's the pull I don't
know you didn't do your homework it only
goes one way okay I think I'm good on
the universe okay another fellow goes in
and he says the following it's funny
when I when I need you to explain crazy
theories as if they're supposed to make
sense yeah right here F says Newton
didn't have his uh didn't base his
gravity equation on anything static
again he heard it on
he based it on Kepler's laws especially
equal area swept at equal times okay the
point here is that this law doesn't
understand what static means okay and
and that's the whole issue here so let's
let's go with that let's find out why
Newton's equation is static
gravitational equation is static okay
that's what we need to explain here what
do we mean by Static when we say
Newton's equation is static okay and I'm
going to give you two uh ansers aners to
that one is related to distance and the
other one is related to weight okay so
here let's go with the first one okay
here let me get rid of this one
here oh I got rid of the wrong
one can I bring it back uh I guess no it
doesn't matter here really what it it
was the U oh maybe I can get it back but
let's get this one it doesn't matter
here okay so because this is essenti
the breakdown of what I was going to say
anyways yeah um on the uh uh left hand
side what you have is the distance of
physics and on the right hand side you
have the distance of mathematics the
distance of physics is the one embodied
in his gravitational equation Newton's
it's attributed to Newton so we're just
going to use Newton as the reference so
the gravitational equation Newton's
gravitational equation which you see the
equation up there that one's got a
static distance that's the distance of
physics that means there's separation
between two objects two masses okay the
one on the right is something totally
different which is uh Newton's second
law of motion okay and uh sometimes they
say well we make the F on the on the
left hand side equal to the F on the
right hand side big ER because
qualitatively they're not the same and
you can see there're the different the
differences between them in the case of
Newton's gravitational equation you're
talking about the distance between two
objects it's a static separation static
there's no motion we don't count meters
we don't count centimeters we don't
count we don't use uh meters in physics
that's mathematics and that's what you
have on the right hand side the right
hand side what you have is motion and
you're going to count how many meters
the guy moved or the one object moved
the first one is between two objects the
second one the one on the right is a
single object moving toward away from
something or towards something so we're
looking at the motion of one object and
so we're talking about distance traveled
by one object not the separation between
two objects okay and that's what we have
in Newton's uh Second Law there of
motion and you can see some of the
differences there so when I say that
Newton's um
uh gravitational equation is static I'm
referring to the fact that um that
you're talking about a separation a a a
physical separation between two objects
okay and that's what we mean by Static
and if you go down the line there if you
go to number what is it number six uh
there it says distance is a measure of
weight weight is a static concept okay
weight is a static concept why because
you don't need to move in fact if you
move you in space anywhere you change
your weight okay your weight weight
changes instantaneously as soon as you
take a a single step okay so never take
a step because you you're going to lose
or gain weight okay in physics and of
course they could never answer why that
is the case
why uh as soon as you move in space why
why does your weight change and here uh
here I'm going to illustrate that for
you okay see if we can do this
ah okay astronaut farther away from the
Earth weighs less if we could weigh him
out there he probably weigh 25 kg Closer
by 50 kg and down on Earth he probably
weighs 100 kilograms why you gave the 50
kilogram guy more ropes that's cheating
yeah more ropes why because he's closer
to the Earth every rope in his body is
uh from every atom in his body is
connected to every adom on Earth the
closer he gets to the Earth the more the
um ropes tug independently so if you
take that turn out to Infinity you know
so to speak all the ropes uh come in
together and that's why gravity is so
weak because it acts like a single rope
like a single coaxial as he gets closer
and closer to the Earth he has this
acceleration because the closer he is to
Earth the more uh ropes tug
independently they're not on the same
axis okay and that's what's happening
and but for a given point in space for a
given distance static distance if I were
to freeze that frame
uh the astronaut has a given weight as
soon as he moves an inch closer to the
Earth he weighs
more okay that's what it is and uh so
weight is a static concept because force
in Newton's equation is a static concept
because distance is a static concept
which is confusing because static well
the reason someone would think in fact
even I if someone asked me if weight
were a static concept I would have
guessed no because if you put him on a
weight on a scale P down yeah it's it's
like the it's like the running boy the
weighed down man okay so let me let me
point out to what you just said okay you
you step on the scale okay as as you
press down right you're getting closer
to the Earth your your your weight you
know the scale starts going up right
because as soon as you put one foot it
goes I don't know 10 kilograms but as
soon as you put your whole weight it it
goes up higher right because you're
pressing down on the scale you're closer
to the Center of the Earth right but
once you stop right once you stand
absolutely still hopefully you don't
move in you know in any direction if you
could achieve that at that point you
have wait for that location only as soon
as you move a little bit to the side you
know whatever your weight
changed okay so if you could stay
absolutely still without moving anything
you know if you could do that then you
would have weight only for that location
because you have the same distance with
respect to whatever other atoms are on
earth okay another uh issue here uh F
says gravitational field field is what
the experiment of Cavendish proved we
talked about the Cavendish experiment
the other day with a measuring of the
value of the constant G okay field is
the space field is a space space I
thought was nothing but he says field is
a space of the gravitational interaction
between two bodies with mass furthermore
it could be the Infinity of space space
is infinite what do you mean space is in
is is space a physical object or not if
it's a physical object it's finite and
if it's in infinite it can't be an
object because an object is that which
has shape so he's got a contradiction
saying Infinity of space No Such monster
in physics okay again these are words
that they fed him in his brain and he
just accepted it from the monastery he's
got to think that there can't be
Infinity of space either space is an
object and is finite or it ain't an
object in which case infin the word
infinity doesn't even apply okay it is
space of interaction between two magnets
whatever that is the space of
interaction okay it was proved by mag I
like the fact that they prove proof
means that someone talking we finished
he already proved it yeah no but uh
proof means that someone convinced you
of something that's all proof means the
word proof belongs to religion in fact
um I mean what I always say is proof is
persuasion yeah it means to say someone
convinced you of something and that's
why you believe it it's proof to you not
to the your neighbor anytime you hear
the word proof just listen to the word
persuasion yeah pers it means I I want
to win over you in the argument so I say
they proved it and and you're wrong it's
creepy I mean it's it's you should
accept it it's a little disorienting
when someone makes those two that
comparison that proof is persuasion but
it's like like I wish that weren't true
cuz I like Everyone likes the word proof
it's just it's it's solid because proof
means that my religion is stronger means
you can finally put a steak in the
ground and I can build a house here no
it's still wobbly no it's still
persuasion there's nothing okay another
fell says a force is when an object
moves okay that's a force an object
moves because it interacts with another
object or field so we have a force
interacting with a field great we have
two concept force with field uh this
moon is called Energy another
concept and it's what makes things
happen yeah I guess uh we have all these
Concepts interacting see this is the
problem when an object moves but see but
see this is this is the issue the issue
is that all these people are using
concept force field energy are all
concept mathematical concept and they
have them interacting they say oh this
the force interacts with a field and the
field with an energy and or we call it
energy it's all Concepts mathematical
Concepts that have no place in physics
physics we have to explain the mechanism
why a pencil falls to the floor so to
speak it's a weird way of saying of
talking it's like if I
said my field of you engulfed something
yeah it's a weird way to talk when
you're using these
Concepts interacting with the world no
your field you didn't engulf the world
but when you attack that they say oh
you're doing uh word salad you're
attacking it from a semantic point of
view well yeah because you're doing sem
you're doing word salid if you're if
you're introducing Concepts as objects
you're doing the word salid not me okay
so here's another F he says light and
magnetism are proof of the existence of
electromagnetic ropes well keep in mind
that uh the Rope is not something we
prove okay uh we make an assumption we
make an assumption that there is a rope
between ropeik mechanism or mediator
between two atoms okay and with that
we're going to explain okay a mechanism
so we haven't proven the rope we're not
asking you to believe in the rope we're
saying look accept the rope in order to
understand a theory founded upon it
period that's all we're saying okay
we're not saying believe in the Rob and
in this you got to accept it and we're
not here to convince anyone we're here
to explain mechanisms using let's just
understand we really care that everyone
understands the theory and then after
that we don't care right reach their own
but to understand the theory you have to
um it's almost like plausible
deniability or or whatever the term is
where you have to accept certain
assumptions for a time like okay let's
let's yeah just to understand let's okay
if you wanted to explain the hole in the
window okay let's
assume cat did it went through the wall
could that explain this all the all the
things that's the way physics should
work okay okay uh F says the following
says actually it was likeness uh over
300 years ago who thought that the Earth
would could have Arisen from a sun we
were talking about the fact that um
Earth was a star okay and you you put
your stake in that it says Jeffrey
mentioned in one of his videos talking
about uh one of the fellas who came up
with his Stellar metamorphosis or
claimed to have been the originator no
he wasn't it was Alexander Oparin but
this fell says look the liance even beat
Oparin okay and if you look it up
there's the uh reference there
conservapedia light supposed the Earth
to have been once a star okay and he
wrote that in several of his books this
is to say a molten body and incandescent
liquid without explaining how it got
into that state okay what's the issue
the issue is that um liit you know 300
years ago he did not have all the
information at his disposal of what we
have today of you know of new ideas of
how the Sun work how a star works okay
that's the first issue so he had his
ideas and he said you know it could have
been a star but he had no way if if we
would have bring liet today he would not
be able to justify those statements
you're saying he just said it off hand
like he kind of had an idea he said look
it it probably was a star but he he
would not be able to justify it in a way
that you would understand how it got to
the state where it is today in fact he
thought it was a molten uh whatever you
know some kind of mol that somehow
hardened and turned into the Earth okay
but he he would not be able to explain
it in today's term so in that sense I
don't know if we can give lienet credit
we can probably give Oparin a little
more credit even though Oparin said it
in 1926 and if you look at oarent
statement he also um probably should not
be given all the credit because uh he
also thought of it as a molten he he got
that from the nebular uh hypothesis
where you we have this Cloud that
condenses and so he's he's also using
that as a basis but here we are 100
years later I think we can do better no
parent okay so this is the nebular
hypothesis here you can see uh a little
bit of uh illustration of that okay you
have the Sun and you have the planets
and according to the nebular hypothesis
they were all gases just roaming around
that's somehow condensed through gravity
gravitational processes
but the main thing I want to point out
is you can see all those little planets
or the little gases are going to turn
into planets they're residual gases the
big gas is the sun and the little gases
are the ones that are going to turn into
uh planets and here you see our planet
as one of those okay there's our little
uh gas
bulb and it turns into our planet
eventually in other words it condenses
I don't delete those I might need those
for a question have okay I'll keep that
one there but see you can see what's
happening the little Cloud there that's
going to be Earth okay one of those or
any of those are going to be planets
okay yeah and I just want you to focus
on that because we have a different
Theory okay that I'm going to tell you
about it right now you can see the this
turns into the Earth okay okay so that
that was the notion that they had uh
what are we saying instead we're saying
that uh uh if we looked at the um gases
the way we think happened uh the
condensation the Earth was a much bigger
Cloud than the sun why because in order
to make iron Earth apparently has iron
in its Center it had to be a much bigger
U gas cloud and a much bigger Sun that
eventually crushed uh or
compressed um hydrogen into helium and
higher elements and eventually into iron
our sun cannot produce iron according to
the calculations so they say in order to
produce iron you need a much bigger Sun
than our than our a much bigger star
than our sun but aren't we still using
the nebular hypothesis we are but then
the question was or the question is
whether the um gas cloud that made the
Earth was the same gas cloud that made
the Sun that's one issue whether uh
there was a gas cloud millions of years
or billions of years before the one that
made the Sun and that was our Earth in
this vicinity it condensed it created
our Earth it was a star then that star
condensed into a planet what is known as
a black dwarf and eventually there was
another gas cloud which turned into a
sun and our Earth was in the vicinity
and was captured and it started rolling
around so this this is what I'm going to
show you here uh the sizes of the
different gas clouds of three
glass gas clouds that I can compare them
in size here it is okay uh I'm saying
Jupiter small gas uh cloud and it
condensed into uh what is Jupiter today
which is a star that never ignited
because it doesn't have the mass to
ignite the sun was a bigger Cloud but it
was not big enough to make iron there
was not enough matter to compress it so
that it um condenses the center into
iron the Earth had to be a much bigger
Cloud if it's going to crush all the
atoms or crunch them so that it
compresses them into iron uh so that's
in general what what I'm suggesting okay
that's a proposal and uh we can add to
this what is known as the iron
catastrophe okay and that is that uh
when a supernova exploded nearby
somewhere maybe it threw some iron or
some heavy elements like uranium or even
radon or whatever into our neighborhood
and that's why we find it still in our
neighborhood we find uh you know these
elements on Earth and this is more or
less what the iron catastrophe is all
about says look you've got um this
planet and it was in a molten State okay
and so what happened was that um a lot
of those elements heavier elements sank
to the center okay um there was iron
crushing uh you know banging against
other iron some of that fell into the
Earth and then fell into the center of
the earth that's another proposal uh I
don't buy too much into the iron
catastrophe only because uh there had to
be quite a bit of iron floating around
and I don't think that's how the iron
got into the center of the earth I think
the way it got in there is that the
Earth was a star and crunched it on its
own crunched the um hydrogen to helium
into higher elements silicon Etc all the
way to iron and then yes you can produce
a center that is uh iron and that would
also explain why the Earth is
differentiated in fact I'm saying that
any round object in the solar system
right any round object any spherical
object except the flat earth right um uh
any of those uh was a star of some kind
and in the case of smaller ones like you
know little Pebbles like um I don't know
even or the moon I think they were the
size maybe of Jupiter maybe a little
bigger but those ignited or no no I
don't think they they ignite I think
maybe that's maybe why they don't have
any uh gases on their no they have no
Sur uh yeah they are but they don't have
gases on their surface which would
indicate that maybe they were not big
enough uh to or over the centuries
gazillions of years they lost their at
even if they don't ignite I'm sure the
just by the way way the the gra gravity
works on these celestial bodies that
differentiation seems like an
inevitability yeah yeah eventually just
with enough time you're going to have
those layers in fact uh when uh Jeff uh
pointed this out some time ago two three
four years ago I can't remember now when
but uh I I like the theory for the first
time in my life I came in contact with
this Theory finally found out it wasn't
Jeff's but oparin's he already had said
it and and you know I was able to
explain two things I could not explain
since the days of high school and that
is why they're round and why they're
differentiated and round and
differentiated that's a star you know so
the Earth was a star that turned into a
cinder known as a black dwarf that's the
way I look at it um did I hear you right
you don't think uranium and these
heavier elements were made on Earth I'm
not sure about that because there's
another problem with that and you should
keep this in mind uh for anyone who
wants to tackle the problem and that is
you find all this stuff on the surface
the question is how did it get on the
surface of the Earth okay now was that
brought in by some asteroid but you find
iron on the surface too yeah yeah also
but see not in the quantities that you
would find in the center of the earth
obviously so there could be find chunks
of it so it's it's not perfectly
differentiated let's put it like that
the Earth is differentiated and quite
perfectly differentiated the question is
why do we find some of these elements
that should not be on the surface why do
we find them on the surface and was that
brought in by asteroids or comets or
whatever is it that the Earth is
differentiated except the surface is the
surface like the the wild card that's
where the iron catastrophe comes in the
iron catastrophe just says there was a
lot of metal flying around because there
was a supernova that threw all this
garbage into our neighborhood and here
was the Earth or the Sun you know
condense our our star right it was
condensing and at some point point maybe
a lot of this garbage fell in there and
just ended up on the surface of this
cool star that was trying to cool in as
last moments and that's why it's still
on the surface or somewhere on the
surface maybe some of it was still in a
molten state or in a gas State and some
of that penetrated a little deeper so if
we go you know a kilometer down the
Earth we'll find some iron some uh hold
on does it have to be so complicated if
there's tectonic uh activity and there's
volcanoes could bring it
that's what I'm saying so there's a lot
of processes you can consider there's a
lot of motion on our rocks that's
sending stuff from the bottom to the top
well the point here is there's a lot of
theories that you could Implement say
well why is it here well because of this
Theory why is this that because of
another one my general point is that all
these round objects had to be some kind
of gas that uh condensed and turned them
into star and it could not have been the
same gas that made the sun because the
Earth had to be a much bigger gas cloud
than the sun when when it Formed many
billions of years before our sun the the
Earth was there when the sun picked it
up yeah but the Earth already shed its
husk which is a lot of gas to make the
Sun so the sun right now is using what
the Earth Shed off it could be some of
that gas that from our couldn't from our
surface well uh I'm sure a lot of it is
but I can't say that the big gas cloud
that made the sun came all from the
earth uh maybe where else would it have
come from well it could have been a
supernova exploded through that gas or
that garbage into our neighborhood when
the Earth was still rolling around you
know in the middle of nowhere so uh you
know the the point is there's a lot of
theories to put in there I I don't buy
the nebular hypothesis for the planets
it is for uh the sun and it would be for
the earth when it first formed but what
I'm saying the Earth must have formed
before the sun Earth was a
captured dark um black
dwarf the sun was the last member of our
solar system that's my point okay let's
move on here uh anyways all those are
theories for you to consider I had one
more question okay okay um let's see
what you get there it because the way I
conceptualize our solar system is since
other solar systems are so far away
we're almost like a contained unit when
you talk about self-contained yeah
selfcontained because
I I almost have this this notion not a
theory but this notion that there's no
such thing as a supernova
flinging matter from one solar system to
another that's almost impossible because
they're just so far away you talk about
the birds speak and stuff like that okay
but you have novas and supernovas and I
can imagine that when they shed all that
skin that's a lot of that's a lot of AC
cross solar systems too like between
Galaxy kind of stuff well you know for
for us the distance from here to the
nearest star is a long a long ways away
but for a Galaxy or for a star yeah
that's just a couple meters away in a
sense so you have to remember one thing
another one is that the uh magnetic
field of our star of our sun extends Way
Beyond Pluto you know so and you say you
know Pluto's out there in the middle of
nowhere it takes hundreds of years to
get there you know for the for the sun
uh it's got its magnetic field around
that and Beyond cuz I was wondering
assuming our so system were
self-contained yeah and assuming you
can't turn matter into nothing nothing
into matter the basic Assumption of our
whole thing yeah then would that imply
that our solar system repeats over time
what do you mean repeats well because if
the sun explodes yeah scatters you know
uh uh matter all over then the nebular
uh hypothesis starts again you start
convening to make a new Sun yeah like if
the sun explodes and destroys the Earth
you're going have all this just kind of
matter floating around in our solar
system then it's going to start the
process all over again of reconvening
into the Earth Sun yeah that's going to
turn into a black star and then the our
now sun will black DWF yeah then our now
sun will uh come after that is it just
like uh like yeah in other words now the
sun becomes a becomes a planet yeah yeah
but is it just a repeating process I
think it I think to some degree it is
and maybe you can pitch in there you
know supernovas that could be throwing
garbage also into the neighborhood so
you know all I'm saying is we have to
look at all these theories and put them
all together we can't just go with a
nebular hypothesis and say oh yeah there
was a cloud and a big cloud was the sun
and the little clouds was the earth I
don't think that works I I think if
you're going to do this you're going to
have to look at a lot more variation
you're going to have to include stuff
like the iron catastrophe could have
happened uh Supernova throwing garbage
into our neighborhood molten uh state
where comets and asteroids bring garbage
into your uh planet and what's going to
become the planet I think we got to look
at all these processes and try to you
know get a a better idea of how our
solar system was really formed oh yeah I
ask because one of my one of the most
interesting topics to me is the
repeatability of the universe assuming
there is no you know beginning frame or
ending frame right if it's just kind of
eternally there then you almost have to
by defin at some point explain
the the whole I don't want to say life
cycle but like Universe cycle like how
is it that this wasn't the first Earth
it wasn't the first Universe you know I
think the it's it's an ongoing process
but it's it's fun to explain that whole
process because it isn't linear no no of
course not it's it's cyclical human
history on Earth is linear but the
universe the way it it kind of recycles
itself isn't and it's just always
interesting to me how is it that when
the sun explodes that a new earth is
made well even worse like I say there
never was a first human being in the
universe because uh when you go farther
back in the past uh there had to be some
human somewhere in the universe and if
you go a million years in the past there
had to be some human somewhere in the
universei and and when you start to
think of it if matter cannot turn into
space and space cannot turn into matter
the universe has always been there and
there was never a first human being we
always have this thing about origin you
know starting you're born H that doesn't
happen with the father Universe he was
always there he's still gone and we
don't understand that it's weird the way
I always explain it to myself if we were
once that means we will always be yeah
it's one of those weird like sci-fi
things and some human will come after us
after us somewhere gets trippy and weird
Okay couple more issues here one file
says bill says the black stuff is space
this is irrational the black stuff is
The Ether well he hasn't told us what
the ether is he just says the black
stuff I guess he's referring to space
right and black stuff is not stuff that
stuff that you see say is black that's
known as space and space is not a thing
so it's not stuff okay so again you have
to tell us what the ether is and unless
you can Define The Ether or point to it
uh one of the two either it's a concept
and you define it or it's a thing and
you point to it and say That's The Ether
you got to show us some kind of shape a
drawing a picture a photograph a is it
always a sea of balls huh isn't it isn't
The Ether always drawn as a sea of balls
I don't care they can draw it as a ball
but then you got to tell me what's
outside the ball giving it shape okay
that that's the tricky part win with
you okay so here we have another fellow
also brings up The Ether he says I'd
really like to know whoever said The
Ether was made of particles that was me
okay yeah everyone said that ether being
part of this complete nonsense okay the
only ones I know of the electric
Universe quacks they think it's made of
imaginary neutrino what else could The
Ether be if not balls well this is the
issue the issue is this fell you can see
as as all ether is yeah the all ether is
uh how do we Define an ethers here let
me Define ether is for you and that'll
tell you everything an ether a person
who cannot Define the word ether will
tell you what it is yeah that's what an
ether is is never never has an eist who
came to this channel ever been able to
define the word ether or point to it you
know put a put a picture and say look uh
here's the ether over here you know uh
look at it and tell and and now you'll
know what the ether is and it doesn't
mean the true uh genuine super duper
ether it's The Ether he's got in his
brain how does conceptualize yeah I need
to know how he conceptualized it I would
like to conceptualize it as well in that
for matter I mean even just to
understand it like balls we can guess
what you have in your brains you know if
you're going to present The Ether first
of all you have to decide whether it's a
concept yeah or an object if it's a
concept Define it tell me what the
meaning of the word ether is according
to you if you think it's an object draw
it put a picture on your ner and say
look bill there's The Ether okay and of
course if you put a shape you got to
tell me what's on the background because
a lot of people like this well says uh
The Ether is space okay but space is not
stuff well that's the thing according
there's a there's a very low chance that
we mean the same thing when we use the
word space when he says space we
understand nothing yeah nothing but in
his mind he's got something else okay
then put it there if if you think it's a
thing uh just draw it and tell us what
is the background that gives it shape
very simp you want to back door the
space at any at any cost okay let's
continue here we got a couple issues
well let's uh we're going to skip over
this I'll probably treat it next time uh
we're going to move into the subject
matter of today which is oh we didn't
start yet yeah we haven't started dark
energy and as uh you know some of this
serves as a background because a lot of
the problem with dark energy right has
to do with language has to do with
people not defining their terms or using
Concepts as physical objects and those
that's where we draw the line we have to
stop them there and say look concepts
are over here objects are over there
every word in the dictionary falls under
one of those two categories objects we
can point to and name and say that it
that's it and uh it's an object got
shape and Concepts first don't have
shape and you must Define them I was
telling him yesterday that what he does
in a lot of ways is very much like
coding or programming because you have
to Define your variables Reg rigorously
you have to have a very clear need to
understand it you need very clear
definitions whether it's a number you're
talking about or a word you're talking
about or you know what category it's in
it's very very rigorous like you can't
cheat or else the computer will not
understand you yeah but the thing is
with humans you can get away with murder
because we're very
poetic since we since we can kind of
under I see what you're saying yeah
that's one of one of the issues that the
other that we're we do a lot of poetry
especially people who want to do physics
that's one of the problems the other
issue is that um the running boy fell
sounds like a normal thing to us a lot
of people got used to using the language
that they were taught in high school
especially right and they never
questioned you know uh how we're using
Concepts as physical object I mean you
look at any textbook of physics and and
where does it start it start starts by
telling you about Concepts this is force
okay and this is mass and this is
acceleration all those are Concepts
physics is about object you can't do
physics without an object so the first
thing you would got have to Define is
the word object and not a single
textbook of physics on planet Earth ever
defined the word object but a thing is I
just think it's very interesting how you
got very programmer with your physics
and I was going to say about that that's
when you get into real nitty-gritty okay
and I wanted to say about that you know
in a computer uh if if you don't program
you know what what you were saying now
if you don't program the word you the
right way the program doesn't know what
to do there you have to be very specific
very objective wor it's worse you won't
know what you meant that's what I was
trying to tell you well I care about the
chat G he doesn't know that we're
trouble but it comes back to this the
just understanding physics in general if
if I'm reading my own codes sometimes
and I named the variable in a way that I
don't understand I won't know what I
meant two months ago which is which
which which adds to all the confusion
where I'm like okay what what did I mean
like forget if I believe whatever just
understanding what is on P paper is hard
because the variables are
all okay misnamed so let's get on with
uh with uh dark energy and for this we
have to understand uh how this thing
started more or less okay it starts with
a big bang that's relativity
relativity's version of how our universe
began just said a minute ago that the
Universe never began it's always been in
there uh mathematics has reached a
different conclusion they said look uh
there was an explosion 14 billion years
ago uh some call it an explosion other
people don't like the word explosion but
that's why uh they say it's not really
an explosion and it's a long story but
it
goes what else is that it's not a hang
grenade you know that just exploded but
uh but it is it ain't but it is okay and
here it is uh this is this is the way
bunch of stuff flying out of an
epicenter we we had this okay there was
this explosion yeah not not it's not an
explosion it's just it's just a very
that's a hand grenade that exploded
throwing all this debris that's quick
expansion that's and the first dot the
first dot that you see just as soon as
it appears that's known as a singularity
how that Singularity got there they say
well we that's un an unscientific
question because we have no way of
verifying or testing or whatever okay so
uh what the religious people do is say
hey we agree with you but you forgot to
put God in the picture God created God
one frame before that very easy but see
the so-called scientist the
mathematician they don't like it okay so
what happened we have we you just missed
them God just came by so we had this
explosion okay and this is what happens
this is the sideways view of
this explodes and it builds this little
cup this little uh
glass uh tilted glass right and what
you're seeing there each one of those
lines uh that's time okay so you can see
that the explosion led to this time
thingy and that last one the W map there
that's uh uh covering the the end of the
cup that's our present state in other
words that's a crosssection of time and
we're all living on that flat
universe as they call it because they
believe in the flat universe so not flat
Earth but flat they're not flat are you
crazy no it's a flat universe we've
upgraded so we live on that flat
universe okay but then uh what they do
is they show it in this way okay because
uh you have to visualize it in in this
direction for us to understand it in our
3D world and it's uh like
this okay you're supposed to see it like
that our universe is a ball that is
exploding it's a balloon that's
inflating okay and as you can see all
the galaxies there are flying apart and
a little cticu is that's light the light
is being stretched as the uh Universe
expands and of course uh people have one
question usually and they say well
what's the white stuff that gives shape
to the ball and that's when they say
well it's an unreasonable question un
scientific question because um uh on the
one hand uh the universe is not
expanding into anything that's one
answer that you get the other one is
well we don't know and we have no way of
proving it oh wait hold on we got the
gray stuff that's expanding but what's
also the white stuff of the backdrop we
have two questions but that's the
question well the no the the gray stuff
is space that's why the white stuff is
not space okay so white stuff is the
gray stuff is space yeah we we know that
what space is that's a gray stuff that's
expanding really it's not space sorry I
I I will qualify that it's space
time okay it's A Spacetime this is a 3D
version of our 4D Universe okay so it's
AOS you're supposed to imagine it in 4D
if you can and we don't know what the
white stuff is maybe it's a Fifth
Dimension 10th Dimension what are the
yellow dots and the yellow dots you can
think of those as stars or galaxies and
the C qes are light going from one
galaxy to the next as the universe
expands it stretches light the uh
wavelength of light okay does that mean
that light and that's why that's why all
the galaxies are red shifted meaning
they're receding from us because light
takes longer and longer to get our but
worse keep keep that gift there
uh does this mean that light doesn't
take doesn't travel at the same speed or
what something like that because the
distance is getting yeah but remember
you know what I mean no no but remember
remember the issue the issue here is
that if if if I'm I'm running away from
you and I turn a light on there's more
distance for the for the light to travel
not for light not for light because
Einstein said light always travels at
the same speed no no but hold it you got
to understand it that's where the
equation comes in little C 300,000 km/s
is equal to wavelength times frequency
meaning when the frequency goes up
wavelength goes down and vice versa that
means all you're doing is stretching the
wavelength but that means now you have a
lower frequency but the light is still
taking longer to get not not because
it's not because it's traveling slower
but the distance is getting bigger yeah
yeah but that's why well they're saying
that all these galaxies will never get
to them because they're flying away
faster than light yeah or even faster
than light yeah because the uh universe
is ballooning faster than light can
travel that's my that's the that's
wouldn't that mean that they're just
standing in
place if the
balloon gets bigger faster than light no
yeah then we shouldn't be able to even
see any other galaxies yeah but uh the
light never gets to us yeah of the
distant ones yeah the ones that are
closer by they're not as fast faster in
light but the ones distant that are
farther away from some regions are
getting further away faster than other
regions the farther a galaxy is from us
the faster it's receding
so the ones closer yeah we can see those
but but the day will come when we can't
see those either okay so um so who came
up with all this stuff well here we have
our three Heroes J Mater uh Albert
Einstein and Edwin Hubble Edwin Hubble
was an astronomer he looked there he
says hey all the uh all the galaxies are
recor all red shifted and uh George the
manager centy said that you know he came
up up with this big bang notion Albert
Einstein never believed in The Big Bang
Theory okay uh some people dispute that
so they they're still I guess the jury
is still out but good old Albert uh he
he did not approve of a lot of stuff
that they made of his theory he never
believed in quantum mechanics uh he
didn't believe in black holes he in fact
he did talk about that he wrote papers
against that he didn't believe in
gravitational waves and there's a fight
whether he believed in Big Bang or not I
take the position that I haven't found
proof evidence you know in his writings
that he actually believed in Big Bang
the do you think all the physicists were
just kind of waiting until he died so
they can put a bunch of words in his
mouth you know what he what else he said
he he thought my theory was true too
they made a hero of him yeah but it's
like they're waiting come on I need you
to die so that we can fill your mouth
with a bunch of words they made him a
reluctant leader of the movement okay
because uh Einstein died a Broken Man in
in in intellectual terms he never could
figure out the gut the grand unified
theory so he was a little uh frustrated
that he died 1955 before he could figure
that out I think a lot of people are but
he disagreed with a lot of stuff that
everybody that came around him or or
after him he disagreed with a lot of
their stuff but he couldn't do anything
about him they say hey you're our hero
that guy's rolling around in his grave
right now stop please okay so um here we
talked a little bit the other day about
this uh which is Einstein's
gravitational constant there and uh
We're not gonna we're not interested in
in all these little letters and
variables and so on we're just
interested in one thing and that's the
gravit the cosmological constant okay
and that's that Lambda G sub muv okay
what's the issue that by the way that's
a mate a tensor and a tensor is simply a
different version of a scaler which is a
Vector is a complex scaler a matrix is a
complex vector and a tensor is just a
complex Matrix just more sophisticated
Matrix people understand more or less
what a matrix is tensor is the same
thing that's why you have the 1 two 32
1754 because that's what the muv
represents but we're not interested in
all this stuff we we want to understand
what this means we're just talking about
a position on a gra no no these are yeah
no it's just see because these equ this
is a an equation that represents many
equations okay so you got to look at it
like that but what we're interested in
here is what what does this mean in
physical terms and the one I want you to
focus on is the cosmological constant
which uh Einstein had uh quite a bit of
trouble in he put it in he took it out
he put it in he took it out he didn't
know what to do with the playing with it
cosmological constant and the important
thing there is first of all that is the
uh variable
uh in this equation that represents dark
energy today and I want to focus on the
word constant I want you to see that it
is a constant okay I want you to keep
that in mind throughout the chat today
okay it's a constant the G is a constant
yeah the Lambda Lambda is a constant
okay the whole thing this cosmological
constant is a constant okay hopefully
people know it's a collection of well no
constant means it doesn't VAR there's no
variable but the tensor is yeah yeah is
three is a constant and a tensor is a
collection of it's um it's um it's a
matrix again the best way to visualize a
mat people more or less understand the
word Matrix tensor is just a matrix okay
just a more sophisticated one but this
is the point here we have it okay ah uh
this dark energy is supposed to be the
stuff that's pushing everything outwards
red okay yeah it's uh the expansion of
space and time okay important to include
time in there but then the question is
what's the black stuff it's pushing
against okay that's important and uh and
of course they say well that black stuff
that's around it against which it's
pushing um we don't know what that is or
it's an irrational question or
unscientific question because we have no
way of proving it through an experiment
blah blah blah okay so that's that's the
answer to that okay so that's what we're
talking about we're talking about the
expansion of SpaceTime that's what
you're ing at there okay I wish you
could do that in court that's an
unscientific
question okay what's the problem with
that well uh all the galaxies are
receding you know they're all red
shifted according to the establishment
and red shifted means that something is
going farther and farther away from you
if it was approaching you would be blue
shifted it's like the Doppler effect you
know the train approaches you you and
when it passes
you and so the the the lower pitch that
means it's receding and that's what
they're saying happens with light we
have a little problem with that and the
problem is that the local group the
Galaxy which are in uh in our vicinity
there's like 54 now there used to be
like 20 now they found like 54 of them
they're all blue shifted uhoh and
they're coming towards us and so the
question is hold it you have this
balloon right it's expanding all
galaxies should be receding but the ones
in the local group are coming towards us
they're blue shifted how do they explain
that well yeah it's easy to explain
don't say tell me un scientific question
come on no no it is a scientific
question they have a scientific answer
the answer is that gravitational forces
and electromagnetic forces are
overcoming the expansion of uh caused by
dark
energy so dark energy does its POS it's
as much as it can to push everything
apart but gravity fortunately whatever
that is and electromag magnetism
whatever that is are bringing everything
in the vicinity closer together because
they're too close to us and the question
is here are they that close I mean you
took about Andromeda galaxy right and
Andromeda is 2.2 million light years
away that's close enough for Gravity to
be pulling and electromagnetism to be
pulling and overcoming dark energy which
is doing its best to push everything
apart you know so you got to think about
that and so here uh I I just wanted to
point out here's a good old Andromeda
okay okay that's what it looks like and
it's uh that's a big picture of it but
really it looks like a little dot in the
sky and you say well that's so far away
how come that one's not being pushed by
all that dark energy that's pushing
everything farther away and remember uh
that Galaxy that you're staring at there
is bigger than the Milky Way okay so uh
and these are the two biggest galaxies
in our vicinity the uh uh what's theam
is the the biggest one and the second
biggest one is the Milky Way what's the
furthest blue shifted
Galaxy well the the as far as I know I
don't know that the answer to that but
as far as I know all only the ones in
the local group are blue shifted but I
don't know if they found I guess they
found no other one because all the other
ones are red shifted or farther away and
the question is whether they're um
assessment is correct and let me give
you a different version of that so that
for you to consider okay it's based on
the Rope model if you take a rope okay
any rope and you string it across from
one PL from One Tree in the forest to
another one far away two kilometers away
okay and you make it as tight as
possible you just you know whatever
means you have for making it tight you
will note that uh closer to the
ends uh the links are shorter and as you
get to the center of the Rope you know
to to that whole Space there if you get
to the center the links are a little
longer okay and uh that's all I want to
show you it's known as tired light okay
the the phenomenon is known as tired
light be hard to see it with a good Rope
though and there you have it okay so you
have two galaxies closer to the galaxies
you have high frequency and um the links
are shorter but as you get to the center
between them you would expect the and
here's exaggerated but the point here is
the links should get longer and longer
that means that if we're receiving
signals from that Center they would be
red shifted that doesn't mean that the
Galaxy is receding it just means that
we're staring at um part of the rope
that is red shifted yeah so you're
saying it's just far away doesn't mean
going away correct it just means that uh
the Rope towards the center were is
going to look like uh uh red uh red
shifted and in the case of galaxies
which are in the in our vicinity well
they're blue shifted because they are uh
coming towards us because of gravity so
I don't doubt that the ones close by are
coming towards us and our blue shifted
it it doesn't imply that the ones
farther away are red shifted meaning
they are red shifted but it doesn't mean
that red shift means that they're
running away from us well technically
blue shift also wouldn't mean that
they're coming towards us it could just
mean that the light that they're giving
off is in tense enough in frequency that
it just doesn't get tired by the time it
gets to us my point is that my point is
that there are other versions that
doesn't mean that the universe is
expanding and then you have the question
of what do you mean the universe oh yeah
there's no such thing as the universe
universe is a concept because it
involves a relation between space and
matter that's what Universe means space
and matter so there's two thingies there
and it can't be a thing then which one's
getting and and aside from the fact that
you cannot make a picture of the
universe because the the universe is
space and space is not a thing therefore
can't take a picture of you can't take a
picture of that uh it's nothing it's
that which doesn't have shape that's
what space is so you can take a picture
of all the matter if you had God's
camera you know stay all the matter
going away from each other makes more
sense but you cannot take a picture of
space sorry and so space uh cannot be
expanding but it's not a thing okay but
then what happens uh according to the
establishment we have this issue where
you have gravity warping time space time
right and what you're doing not only
warping space you're warping time
because time is part of space time is
this structure 4D structure unimaginable
4D structure that they use uh in
mathematics to try to exp uh not explain
but describe uh mathematically uh how
gravity works and so they say you have a
mass in this case the sun weighing down
this 40 canvas which is made uh of space
and time three um Dimensions as they
call it which are not Dimensions uh and
time Dimension none of them are
dimensions they're all number lines okay
because they're talking about math and
about physics but they warp them and
they say this is what causes the um
warpage of SpaceTime and because
SpaceTime is Warped then the Earth rolls
around like the little ball on or
roulette okay that's why it can't fly
away from our solar from the Sun you
know from the solar system but then the
question if if that's space and time
what is the black stuff that gives you
know contrast to the uh rent uh net and
of course they never answer that
question they say well it's an
irrational question because you're not
you're not supposed to take it literally
you know the analogy a lot of problems
with that why aren't people being
crushed why can people go to the Moon
there's a lot of but I think the main
one here is that uh you know that you're
warping time that's what I want you to
focus on because we're talking about
dark energy and so we have we have two
issues here the first one is that
gravity is the warpage of time let's
forget about space for a second we're
going to warp time right that's what
we're doing with gravity but then we
have dark
energy and that's pushing everything
apart okay yeah and what did we say at
the beginning we said we have this
explosion and this time is you know
expanding out there and that's what's
pushing you know the galaxies and the
stars and the planets apart okay so we
have two things we have uh you know a
planet a mass right weighing down
SpaceTime and then we have SpaceTime
time really let's forget about space
time also pushing expanding because you
had that balloon right it was pushing
everything apart that's time expanding
there so we time doesn't only warp yeah
time also expands it's getting blo it's
bloating okay and so um I never thought
about that here we have uh here we have
one aspect of that that's the time
bending that's one aspect that they want
to give you okay but then uh it's doing
this as well it's uh also expanding
while it while it
bends Lego says they can't draw it you
just put the word time yeah yeah it's a
bending time but at the same time that
time bends it's also expanding so so so
time time is doing two things so keep
that in mind it's very very dangerous I
mean that's stupid you have to write the
word time because you don't have a
picture okay so I hope you understand
what's happening here not only is uh is
um time being used for to explain
gravity which is really the opposite of
what they're talking about about because
they say dark matter causes gravity why
because it weighs down space time so now
you're bending time locally but then you
have this time thingy which is expanding
pushing everything apart which is
Against Gravity so the anti-gravity is
dark energy it's made of time right but
uh at the same time it's also part of
gravity which is what is bending to
explain gravity locally or in our
neighborhood I need more shots but but
but now that's throw there uh uh a
couple more problems with that the first
one is that what did I say at the
beginning that cosmological constant was
dark
energy it's a constant yeah but time is
not constant so there's a contradiction
because dark energy is this expanding
time which is variable and they're
talking about because it's expanding and
bending and doing all this good stuff
but the gravitational constant that
they're using is a constant meaning it
doesn't vary but if the hold on but if
the I'm going to add another one
now but is it a number that's constant
or a relation that's constant it's a
it's a variable lamb it's a it's a
component of Einstein's uh equation that
is a constant but is it a relationship
that's constant or is it actual
variables that's constant what do you
mean a relationship like for example eal
mc^2 that could be constant even though
the varable are
changing yeah if if they all uh increase
at the same time but here you have that
whole unit which is supposed to be a
Conant because it's called a constant
but at the same
time it represents the dark energy which
is what these people are investigating
mathematically and also the astronomers
but here you have a contradiction
because in one instance they treat it as
a Conant in another instance they say
well this dark energy is pushing
everything away but that dark energy is
what dark time really right and so you
have this expanding this variable
compared to a constant but let me let me
add one more in there just just to throw
it in there I wasn't confused enough no
no now now you're going to be confused
forever you have Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle or principle of
indeterminacy whichever way you want to
call it okay so you have this uh
Heisenberg's uncertainty uncertainty
principle which applies to quantum
mechanics which is the world of the
small right but uh Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle has two versions
one is that uh if you have the more you
know about position the less you know
about motion okay about displacement and
the more you know about displacement the
less you know about position which is
which I like to say is the more the ball
stands still the less it moves and the
more it moves the less stand still okay
that's one aspect but then there's
another aspect this is where you got to
hold on to your Bridges
uh the more you know about energy the
less you know about time and the more
you can measure time the less you know
about energy and here we have dark
energy being pushed everything aside
which is made of time but here they're
saying that the the dark time is the
same thing as the dark energy because
energy is made of time in in the in this
uh in this uh gravitation in this uh
constant in in the constant so so you
have you have two issues here you you
have the the world of uh quantum
mechanics that says the more you can
measure the energy the less you can
measure time and vice versa and here you
have energy which is made of
time done you're done right there
already and we have a contradiction
there between mechanics but then how do
they plan to reconcile general
relativity which says this nonsense to
uh Quantum mechanic which is another
isn't that why they're never going to
get to the gut I'm sure mean you said
earlier Einstein talking about anymore
you were saying that Einstein must have
he he died intellectually bankrupt
because he couldn't figure out the gut
but I think a lot of people are in that
predicament right now like actual
physicist physicist quotation let's just
say people who are interested in the
subject who can't figure it out yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot of but this is
the problem the problem is that you have
all these astronomers all these
theoretical physic and they're working
on these things and they're looking for
nothing they're looking for dark energy
in dark kind so so here I need you to
look for something that's invisible got
you boss it's like three stooges or some
more or less uh so here's the
conclusions for today okay we have
conclusions we have relativity the
universe is expanding that's what
relativity says right so here are some
of the questions for you to ponder or
ask people uh that are knowledgeable you
I was going to ask you is there more
Dark Energy being created every second
yeah yeah yeah of course even not it's a
constant yeah and that's why time is
expanding because there's we're creating
more energy more time as time goes by
and so we're creating more time as time
goes by we're done it says is matter uh
exploding or dispersing right uh is is
it matter that is separating like a hand
grenade or is it space that is expanding
or both and they say it's both okay so
we have both so nothing this is getting
bigger yeah then the other issue is a
ret have proof that galaxies are
receding is blue shift proof that uh
yeah the nearby galaxies are overcoming
overcoming dark energy and uh you know
um uh coming together you know is What's
Happening Here is the red shift uh proof
that you know everything is exploding is
blue ship proof that everything's coming
together and so the these things have to
be addressed because right now all the
theories are based on this red shift
blue shift thing then you have
relativity U uh gravity
uh uh what is it uh warp time that's
what gravity is under relative warp time
and then uh but gravity is also you know
um you know gravity pushes inwards
because that's what gravity is whether
it's pushed or pulled but they always
have a push because when you have that
uh depression yeah why does it fall
downwards into the hole Yeah Yeah but
the question is it pulling or pushing
you know so it doesn't matter yeah so so
they always have Push gravity and dark
energy does the opposite push outwards
so one pushes inwards the other one
pushes outward they're they're against
each other I as as an aside I would love
to see you interview a physicist just
you interview them okay so here we have
um Dark Energy what is that it's the
expansion of space time right so let's
forget about space for a second here
it's the expansion of time yeah but the
cosmological constant is constant it
doesn't expand it's supposed to be
constant and but we're saying that it is
dark energy is actually dark energy has
time in it it's getting bigger
even so it can't be a constant on one
hand and also be treated as something
that expands or changes right then you
have Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
right you can say simultaneously measure
energy and time right you can't do both
of them at the same time so we have a
problem because energy dark energy is
time and so I'm suggesting you know that
maybe what we should do is call it dark
time from we live in dark times we yeah
t yeah we
do we live in dark times so we're living
in very dark times okay and and I
haven't got to the uh Extinction segment
but we'll do that next week Jesus okay
folks uh we have anything that people
want to ask there maybe something
interesting I was looking through it
yeah didn't see anything that stood out
a lot of interesting okay folks what
we'll do we'll look through the
questions that people made and uh we'll
answer them next time okay we'll see you
then byebye it's been
fun